some of you might be wondering why are
we even worried about this Drake
Equation or the number or why are we
even tempted to go through this thought
experiment of the number of detectable
civilizations in the galaxy when we
don't have a clue of some of these
assumptions we don't know what fraction
of planets capable of sustaining life
actually do generate life we don't know
of all of the the planets that have life
what fraction of those planets go on to
have intelligent life and what fractions
of those civilizations go on to having
to using electromagnetic radiation as a
form of communication we don't know
these answers in fact we probably won't
know some of these answers for some
sometime so what's the point of going
through this exercise and that is a
valid point of view the Drake Equation
or even this little equation that we've
set up here it's not an equation in the
traditional sense we can immediately
apply it to some engineering problem or
some physical problem or anything like
that I view it more as a bit of a
thought experiment and what's
interesting about it is it kind of
constructor our thought around the
problem and I think that's where it has
the most value will probably not get a
solid number on this anytime soon but it
does lead us to thinking about these
interesting problems of what does it
mean or what what do we think has to
happen for a planet to start state
getting life even if it has all the
right ingredients and then what and then
what does it mean for things to
eventually get to the point that you
have intelligent life and you know in
all fairness to this is that probably
200 years ago there would have been no
way to even have a decent estimate of
the number of stars in the galaxy now
we're starting to do an okay job on that
twenty or thirty years ago it would have
been viewed impossible to say the
fraction of stars that have planets but
now we're finding exoplanets we're
seeing stars wobble we're finding we're
getting more and more accurate
instruments so we can start to think
about planets that are closer to the
size of Earth's or even we're making
we're making headway there there's other
indirect methods to think about well you
know some of these exoplanets look like
they're in the right zone and they look
like they have the right chemical
signature based on other information
that we're getting that then maybe they
are capable of sustaining life so as
time goes on and as technology improves
we might be able to get better and
better and
this but with that said it was not going
to happen anytime soon and the real
value of all of this is really to
structure our thought about really a
super super interesting topic now the
other thing I want to talk about is a
slight clarification of what I talked
about in the last video in the last
video for this L I said it's the
civilizations lifespan but what's
actually relevant is the civilization
the lifespan of the civilization while
it is detectable so detectable so it
doesn't matter if the civilization is
around a hundred thousand years but it's
not releasing any type of thing that we
can detect that's not what we care about
we care about that the five thousand
years or the ten thousand years or the
hundred thousand years when they are
actually using some type of some type of
communications or some type of some type
of electromagnetic radiation that we can
eventually detect once those things
reach us now the other thing I want to
make it clear is we're talking about the
number of detectable civilizations in
the galaxy right now and I'll right now
in in quotation marks because we're not
talking about a civilization that is
maybe even a peer civilization with us
that developed developed radio
communication on the order of a hundred
years ago because frankly they would
have to be no more than a hundred light
years away for us to be able to detect
those signals now if they were on the
other side of the galaxy we wouldn't be
able to detect their signals for another
for tens of thousands of years so when I
talk about now I'm saying that the
signals are getting to us signals
getting signals received the signals are
being are being received right now
signals are so you could have a
civilization that developed radio 70,000
years ago but there's 70,000 light-years
away
and maybe they collapse 10,000 years
later but we're just receiving their
first radio signals so that's that would
be a civilization that I would count in
this in this equation we're setting up
and so just to make sure we understand
it just so and then we can play with
some numbers let's remind ourselves this
is the number of stars our estimate of
the number of stars in the galaxy you
multiplied by this you now know the
number of stars in the galaxy that have
planned
you multiply by this n sub P the the
average number of planets capable of
sustaining life and these first three
terms will give you the average number
of planets in the galaxy that the number
the total number of planets in the
galaxy that have been capable of
sustaining life at some point in their
history multiply it by this this is the
number of planets in the galaxy that
have sustained actual life not just
capability of it they actually had life
on them at some point in their history
multiply it by this this is the fraction
that have developed intelligent life on
these planets the number of planets with
intelligent life at some point in their
history multiply it by this fraction all
of these terms you have the number of
planets in the galaxy that have
developed that have had intelligent life
that got became detectable that started
emitting some type of radio signature we
don't know some type of thing like that
at some point in their history so it
over here all of these first six terms
tell us the number of detectable
civilizations that occurred at some
point in the history of the the stars
the solar system's the planets that are
out there right now but we care about
the ones that are detectable now we
don't care about the ones that came and
went and their radio signature went past
us while we were you know still living
in caves or we were hunter-gatherers we
care about the ones that the radio
signatures are receiving us now and
that's why we have this little term
right over here so this is the
civilization of I guess you could say
this is the length of the detectable
civilization so while they were actually
releasing a radio signature divided by
the life of that planet or that solar
system or that star so for any given
star or planet it meets all of these
criteria
what's the probability that it's
releasing its so it's it's at some point
in the history it was there was a
detectable civilization or more that was
releasing a some type of a radio
signature but what's the probability
that it's doing it right now and so
that's the detectable lifespan of that
civilization divided by the life of that
solar system or of that planet because
frankly that the the star and the solar
system of the planet they're all going
to essentially have give or take a few
it's a thousands of years or even a few
millions of years because we're thinking
in the billions here they're going to
have roughly the same lifespan and so if
you have if if let's say let's give and
just to make this a little bit a little
bit more tangible let's say that the Sun
the Sun has a lifespan and let's say
that with the earth and our solar system
has a lifespan of approximately ten
billion years ten billion years and
let's say let's say that us as humans
let me be pretty optimistic about it
let's say that we are detectable as a
civilization for 1 million years so you
know we have our best days are ahead of
us so we have we are we are detectable
for 1 million years so this term right
over here will be 1 million over 10
billion so this will be 1 over 10,000 so
even though we might be around sending
out detectable signals 4 million years
the odds relative to the entire span of
the history of our and I'm making some
simplifying assumptions here but
relative to the entire span of the
history of our planet and our Sun if
someone is just randomly sampling our
solar system at a random time in its
history in a random part of this 10
billion years there's only 1 in 10,000
chance that they'll still they'll be
sampling us at a time that we are
releasing signals assuming that there
weren't any other civilizations on Mars
or Venus or whatever else or that there
weren't any other civilizations on earth
hundreds of thousands of years ago that
we're doing this they would only have a
what they'll definitely only have a 1 in
10,000 chance of detecting us assuming
that they're sampling you know there
could've been a civilization that was
around 3 million years ago and they did
this whole search for extraterrestrial
life maybe they're you know maybe
they're 20 or 100 or a thousand light
years away and they pointed their radio
telescopes at us what a million or two
million years ago they would have
pointed at the direction of our Sun and
they would have not gotten any radio
signals and they're like man when is
this when is extraterrestrial life going
to show up even though the Sun and Earth
does eventually develop us they weren't
able to observe us because when they
sampled was outside of that one in
10,000 window